mandolins I have to say mandolins are
these kind of scary slicers they remind
me of back in the 80s I think there was
some commercial i saw basically every
five seconds called remco or something
and it was this slice and dice thing and
I always used to watch it kind of
fascinated and created thought well wow
I could make whole fun soften two
minutes and mandolins are these very
beautiful aesthetically pleasing kind of
blades that you you cannot very lovingly
and softly cut basically any vegetable
or fruit on and I think they are always
a little bit scary so I don't pull them
out because I don't want my kids to hurt
themselves on it but mandolins are just
so beautiful and there's something very
zen about using them so when I'm having
a moment of quiet in my kitchen I just
want to cut some cucumbers I just pull
out the mandolin even though I can just
do very quickly with a knife